the history of colognes famous cathedral
began with a shrine adorned with 74
figures made from gilded silver it
contains what's said to be the relics of
the three kings the Magi
in the 12th century the Holy Roman
Emperor gave the relics which had long
been kept in Milan to the archbishop of
cologne the old cathedral was too small
to accommodate the pilgrims flocking to
see the relics so a new one had to be
built it was to be a monumental
structure visible from afar in the
Middle Ages Christians traveled great
distances to visit holy sites
work began in 1248 and the Gothic
cathedral was finally completed in 1880
for a time it was the world's tallest
structure Cologne Cathedral welcomes
everyone and there's no entry fee some
20,000 tourists and pilgrims pass
through its doors every day they come to
see the late 13th century Milan Madonna
or the triptych altarpiece of the patron
saints of cologne by Stefan Lana the
passing of the centuries is reflected in
the cathedrals stained glass windows too
they depict everything from biblical
stories to artists Gerhard Richter's
modern play of colors restoration and
conservation of the cathedral and it's
artworks is a never-ending job
built on the remains of the old
cathedral and the ancient Roman city
walls Cologne cathedrals volts hold even
more treasures they show how rich and
powerful the city's Archbishop's once
were the cityscape of colognes old town
is also dominated by its 12 Romanesque
churches
and the ruins of another church provided
the foundations for Columba the art
museum of the archdiocese of cologne
designed by swiss architect peter some
tour the city's newest art museum is
meant to be a place of reflection
there are works highlighting various
styles and errors from two millennia of
Western culture the exhibition space
invites visitors to take a closer look
the historical town hall is a testament
to colognes importance in the Middle
Ages when it was one of the busiest
trade centres in Europe in front of the
Town Hall visitors can see the remains
of the Praetorian the Roman governors
palace and what later became the Jewish
quarter cologne suffered extensive
damage during World War two only a small
part of the old town with its streets
and buildings dating from the Middle
Ages survived the museum Ludvik is well
known outside of cologne
it's named after Elena and Peter ludvík
who endowed their extensive collection
to the city thanks to the generosity of
other cologne art collectors as well the
museum features a collection of 20th
century and contemporary art
here visitors can see everything from
expressionist sculpture to pop art the
museum Ludwig's collection of pop art is
the largest one outside the US all the
icons of this art movement which enjoyed
its heyday in the 1960s are exhibited
here
a stroll along the Rhine is a must for
every cologne visitor the river is as
much a part of the city as the cathedral
it made cologne a trading City and it's
left its mark on the local character the
people of cologne are known for their
easygoing sociability
for nightlife head to the Belgian
quarter colognes young and hip meet at
bussola platts in bars like Hal McCann
Reuter
whether you're here for a day or a
lifetime cologne boasts enough variety
to make everyone feel at home